raid dream
france connue de nelson mandela mes
phrases aussi prononcé ou premier thé ed
en 1984 à monterrey et chacun d'entre
nous un rêve à un moment donné et mon
rêve à partir de la classe de seconde
c'était de devenir géographe ça paraît
étrange voire le monde à l'époque et
sans doute pour vous la géographie n'est
peut-être pas la discipline la plus
passionnante et souvent de téléphoner au
département de géographie me disant
quelle est la hauteur du long blanc
deux mois à peu près 4807 ou 4810 sert
aussi à de la glace ou pas mais on me
disait mais on veut et on fait un quiz
on veut la réponse exacte je ne les ai
pas ma géographie à moi c'est une
géographie du quotidien de tous les
jours de ma famille
si on avait été le matin j'aurais parlé
de la géographie du petit déjeuner vous
avez tous le matins quand vous avez le
temps un petit déjeuner à prendre bien
regarder où vient le café d'où vient la
d'où vient la taz ou via et vous allez
vous promener à travers le monde votre
petit déjeuner va être fabuleux et moi
ce que je veux faire
c'est
vous faire une géographie que vous
pourrez tous faire de ma famille par
hasard mon marié mon grand père était né
en
1884 ça fait une paille
et lui ne savait pas tu avais jamais vu
la planète bleue
ça veut pas ce que c'était il n'avait
jamais vu la terre je pense qu'il
croyait qu'elle était ronde mais il
n'avait jamais vu comme nous et le brave
homme
vosgien
a vu une fois la mer dans sa vie il a
accompagné son fils au havre quand le
fils partait faire des études et il est
allé à lyon lors de la débâcle parce
qu'on l'a obligé à quitter ses vosges
natales pour aller jusqu'à lyon c st-
ses voyages le fils donc mon père lui
est né en 14
il a vécu à belforte presque toute sa
vie
en particulier la mairie lui a largement
une fois sa vie belfortaine assumer il a
largement profité du monde parce qu'il a
pu faire des études aux états unis qu'il
a travaillé pendant la guerre pour les
forces alliées américaines
et de ce fait il a pu voyager un petit
peu
et moi j'ai mis le fils et moi le
coefficient carbone n'est pas bon ça je
le reconnais un géographe ne pas avoir
un bon coefficient carbone j'ai voyagé
de par le monde
très souvent mais je crois que c'est
indispensable
un géographe où tout un chacun doit
reconnaître le local et le monde le
local et le global est faire des aller
retour et c'est pour ça que je suis très
heureux d'être ici parce que je retourne
dans mon local où j'ai vécu pendant 18
ans alors je lis quelques fois
et les ouvrages
de quelques auteurs qu'on trouve à la
foire du livre d'ailleurs plus que les
miens
qui ont beaucoup plus de succès
c'est un livre de jean d'ormesson qui
raconte comment il a vécu dans les ors
de la république des ambassades ou
consulats
puis comment il a fait son caleçon
hypokhâgne comment il a eu était dans
les grands lycées comment il a fait
toutes les grandes écoles
sortant de belfort
j'ignorais ce qu'était cagnes j'ignorais
ce qu est l ena
s'empêche pas qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je fais ma scolarité à belfort et le
lycée qu'on appelait deux garçons à
cette époque puisqu'il y avait un lycée
de filles à l'époque aussi
était un lieu fort sympathique et des
professeurs de haut niveau ils n'étaient
pas tous agrégé mais dévoué
qui m'ont formé qui ont envie donné
envie de faire de la géographie après au
lieu d'aller à paris salle à
l'université de franche comté il y avait
un train pour aller à besançon
raisons de proximité restent les plus
importantes et puis là je suis tombé
aussi sur des bons penseurs et puis des
copains des comme vous en avez tous les
élèves qui sont présents les étudiants
bas ont fait retrouver un tir haut un
petit groupe de huit ou neuf du crédit
mais pourquoi on passerait pas là greg
à paris là greg il faut avoir fait
cagnes confère normale sup un petit
groupe qui s'entend un réseau qui
s'entend qu'est ce que ça fait 10 est un
16 sur les neuf on a eu tous les neuf
l'agrégation quasiment du premier coup
tout ce pour quoi et on nous a mis des
bâtons dans les roues à paris je vais
vous dire quand on arrivait pour les
leçons orale qu'est-ce qu'on nous disait
vous allez retirer les livres à la
bibliothèque
mais les gens normale sup les avait tous
retirés pour qu'on ne les ai pas
heureusement à belfort on avait beaucoup
d'alsaciens on parler l'allemand on
parlait l'anglais
j'ai pris des livres en allemand en
anglais
résultat on a eu l'agrégation
directement l énorme alias ont repassé
l'année d'après
une bonne revanche les périphéries je
crois que de temps en temps ils font un
peu s'amuser avec ce cas là et le
résultat bat l'université de
franche-comté m'a ouvert des portes et
en rencontrant l'ancien franc comtois à
héricourt qui était inquiété doyenne la
sorbonne et m'a dit tu peux avoir une
bourse pour les états unis et oui on y
va et là on a refait un nouveau réseau
partant de belfort réseau franc comtois
réseau monde j'ai raté laine j'ai pas
fait l'ena j'ai pas fait normale sup
mais je me suis créé un réseau monde ce
qui est beaucoup plus important
j'ai pu vivre divers systèmes le système
les états unis système politique du
canada système politique de la suisse
système politique de la france est bien
l'éducation de géographes nous apprend
beaucoup de choses en france si vous
voulez être quelqu'un
j'ai repris de façon tout à l'heure il
faut passer par paris il faut monter
même si vous êtes dans un syndicat
n'importe quoi monte monte monte de
façon être en haut de la sq que je mets
la de la hiérarchie du pouvoir
et ans au
haut de la hiérarchie du pouvoir et
c'est important de comparer des systèmes
c'est la dernière régionalisation qui
m'a surpris elle en a surpris beaucoup
vous franc comtois belfortain
vous êtes avec des gens de nevers avons
senti beaucoup d'atomes crochus je pense
à la question que je me pose c'est vous
franc comtois ou belfortains et vous
franc comtois jeu si on le pouvait
enfreindre vous sentez-vous bourguignon
vous sentez-vous vosgien vous
sentez-vous alsacien vous vous sentez
vous d'elle fort table
question quand même importante si on
voulait en suisse m deux régions deux
cantons ensemble je sais pas qui aurait
le droit de le faire et on pourrait pas
le faire sans vote des personnes à ça
prend du temps regardez l'histoire
jurassienne qui se passe à côté de chez
vous le canton du jura est née d'un
divorce un peu ce que réclame la
catalogne d'un divorce commencé dans les
années soixante dix neuf cent soixante
soixante-dix et l'épilogué elle se
termine et il y à un mois
avec le rattachement de moutier ou
canton du jura
en donnons le pouvoir vient du haut
écrase tout et c'est là le jeu trouve le
drame
fédération confédération qu'est ce qu'on
veut est ce qu'on veut du local du
global est ce qu on veut toutes imposées
par le haut ou est-ce qu'on laisse une
respiration aux régions question que je
me pose avant de dire que tout ça crée
des malaises des mécontentements j'étais
récemment encore en alsace ou des
alsaciens ces alsaciens c'est quand même
une vraie région
je pense que si on a la une
à une certaine époque je venais dans
cette salle les alsaciens aussi et quand
on demandait à une jeune fille de danser
à ça se faisait à l'époque en demandait
on me répondait pas si justement m alors
rien vous pouvez le jeu n'est pas
toujours du succès ans à vous le voyez
et et c'était une période
est intéressante
et je la met en lumière avec ce qui se
passe j'ai dit si on néglige le local
sur néglige les périphéries ce qui se
passe si à plus de services sis à plus
de médecins s'ils appuient hôpitaux
j'appuie le poste il ya plus je pourrais
en rallongé vous avez des beaux exemples
en france avec le massif central
êtes-vous étonné que les gens se sentent
que jeter
non bien regarder ce qui s'est passé
pour le bric site si vous regardez la
carte de nouveau en géographie la carte
du break si c'est les vieilles région
industrielle de l'angleterre centrales
qui ont voté pour y z'ont pas vu
d'étrangers simplement il ouvre y sont
abandonnés
londres a voté contre le break site
l'échos aussi vous avez une leçon
géographie sur la carte vous pouvez
faire un certain parallèle avec la
france regardez je prendre un autre
exemple que vous connaissez tous d'un
bon président america monsieur trump
qui a été
élu par qui
la carte des états unis c'est le centre
le centre rural vielle région
industrielle
qui ont voté tous les états du centre
ont voté trump la zone rouge elle est là
la côte est a voté essentiellement
démocrate la côte ouest à voter
démocrate
regardez fait une analyse soigneuse
regarder
est revenu les niveaux les industries et
vous êtes de nouveau dans des
périphéries oublié alors la leçon
géographique qui est la mienne que je
donne ce soir c'est
n'oubliez jamais les périphéries
malheureusement nos hommes politiques
dans beaucoup de pays centralisé sont
tous formés aux mêmes moules un moule de
centralisation un moule où on impose par
le haut la régionalisation et effet
décidé pour la fin en une nuit vous le
savez
ceci n'est pas tolérable pour le
géographe on doit vous demander votre
avis mais pour ce faire il
faudrait que le local puisse s'exprimer
du local au global on revient au local
que l'on peut comprendre mieux aux cales
des autres le son local à soi
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]